[Applause]
oh yeah
good to see you I'm happy to be here but
let's face facts you are at the top of
your game your show has grown into a
very important business for the network
and for digital
and you have offshoot and you you're
literally on the top and there's that
thing there is that brave bold move that
people take where they go
we're at the best place we're on top and
we're done
when do you know to walk away
look it has it's not easy in any way to
to walk away from something that is so
I mean I'll I'll never work in a better
environment than the one I work in now
nothing about leaving the show it was to
do with not enjoying it I love it but
the truth is it
became a very easy decision because
I always knew it was an adventure and I
never ever considered it to be the final
destination
and
when I was shooting the show mammals
that you're so lovely about two summers
ago and one day I was filming on a
Sunday and I came downstairs it was
about 6 a.m and my son who was 10 at the
time
was sat on the stairs and he said are
you working today and I said I am and he
said I thought
but it's Sunday and I said I know buddy
but this the schedule's just so all over
the place we've just got to get it done
it's only have a tiny amount of time
before we have to go back and do the
show
and uh
his face just kind of dropped
and I got in the car
and uh I called my wife Jules and I said
I've realized best case scenario best
case scenario
we have
six more Summers
where Max is like even remotely wants to
be around us
and I cannot waste another one
so really the choice was to go well if I
want to do this other work that cannot
be at the expense of
our children our family and that is
really all it comes down to I will be a
mess on that last show I will cry my
eyes out but I will know in my core that
the best thing for me and the best thing
for us as a family is to put down some
roots in London and it feels absolutely
right in every single way
all right
[Applause]
and that might be the best advice there
could be but listen to this so my my
son's 11 okay and
you know anyone who has got an 11 year
old child will understand completely
that there is there is there's there's
changes afoot you know there's there's
changes happening and I am
I sat him down the other day
I went up to his bedroom and I said uh
he'd had a real strop about something I
can't even remember what it was
but it was a you know marching
I went up and I said to him
I said can I ask you some questions
he said sure
I said uh
do you think I love you
and he said yeah and I said do you think
I would ever
do anything to intentionally upset you
and he said no I said do you think I am
if only a little bit somewhat smart and
wise he went yeah
I said and do you think I've changed
much in the last four years
he said no I said good they are all the
right answer he scored a hundred percent
I said because here's the thing here's
the thing
in a over the next few years I promise
you you're gonna think I don't love you
you're going to think I am intentionally
trying
to hurt or upset you you're going to
think I am not smart that I don't know
anything and you're going to think that
I've changed
and I need you to know
that you've changed
and I haven't changed and you need to
change
and all we're trying to do
is support you and love you through
these changes
but I need you to remember this
chat now
because it's going to come up a few
times over the next few years and he
went
cool good pairing yeah
[Applause]
[Music]